we are learning more about when it will
get here and how you can get it
joe mohler is live in the convention
center with more details
[Music]
the third vaccine also known as the
johnson johnson vaccine is already being
administered in northern nevada and any
day now it will be here in clark county
now we've been calling this the johnson
johnson vaccine but when people do get
this vaccine when they get their
vaccination card it will be called the
jansen
vaccine that is the pharmaceutical
company of johnson and johnson
for this first shipment 24 thousand
doses came to nevada this week and they
are on their way to this end of the
state
in a copen 19 health district
vaccination meeting today officials
explained they expect to get 17 thousand
vaccines down here in clark county now
that weekly amount is expected to drop
for a week or two of this vaccine and
then pick back up by the end of this
month or early april
they expect this vaccine to be an option
at all clinics and sites soon and they
are focusing on making sure
they are equipped to handle it all we
want to maintain
the high volume that we're doing and we
need to ramp up even more so we're
making some
adjustments in our scheduling right now
uh so
so we also have more discussions next
week when uh we'll meet more with the
state and some of the gaming control
board
officials that are tasked with getting
this out
481 thousand vaccines have been
administered so far and more people
became eligible this week
with the third vaccine coming they will
be expanding hours of operations
the last appointments for the convention
center site will now be at 5
30 p.m and over at cashman center they
will be at 6 p.m
both locations will open at 8 o'clock in
the morning
they do have a message for people out
there who may be waiting to get this
single dose vaccine which is the jansen
vaccine they're urging people to just
sign up and get whatever vaccine that
first becomes available
reporting live here at the convention
center joe mullen 8 news now